[Music]
if you've traveled to Hong Kong chances
are you've stayed or worked here amongst
the skyscrapers of Hong Kong Island but
Hong Kong Island is running out of room
to expand housing is the least
affordable anywhere in the world and you
don't get much for your money
the average sized flat is smaller than
what you'd get in Manhattan and many
Hong Kong is live in apartments not much
bigger than a garage it's because of
this pressure that the next time you
visit were more likely to stay here
across Victoria Harbour in cm sad soy
[Music]
Zim site sorry is not easy to say and
it's often mispronounced so it's nan de
expats as TST today the area is a
growing metropolis packed with a huge
variety of restaurants modern hotels and
sleek museums so it's hard to believe it
once looked like this during the 1880s
it was a watch post for the British
colony and some of the grand old
buildings still remain this is the 1881
heritage building which used to be the
headquarters of the marine police
now it's filled with high-end shopping a
hotel restaurants and bars but most
people come here to take photos
walk down the road a couple of blocks
and you'll come to Hong Kong's iconic
peninsula hotel built in 1928 it has
made appearances in films like James
Bond and The Dark Knight
it's known for its fleet of rolls-royce
phantoms painted in the hotel's
signature green which it holds the
record for the largest single order
[Music]
running through the center of TST is
Nathan Road
what started as a muddy country path
built by the British in 1861 is now a
shot as paradise
Nathan Road is probably best known for
its tailors and the tradition of
tempting or twisting the arms of
tourists walking five handmade suits
start at around three hundred dollars
but for higher quality threads go to
Empire International tailors this
unassuming store is in fact the base of
a global operation this family-run
business sells suits around the world
mostly thanks to word-of-mouth now
you're dressed for dinner head to the
top of one Peking Road Tower this gem of
a Chinese restaurant is made to look
like a hutong or old Chinese alley go up
two floors and you'll find a crow spirit
one of Hong Kong's premium bars it has
some of the best views of the city and
when you get tired of the hustle and
bustle of TM sites I walk over to one of
Hong Kong's most famous institutions the
Star Ferry
running since 1888 this is the oldest
mode of transportation across the
harbour and you can hop on for just 30
cents and enjoy one of the world's most
photographed harbours
[Music]
you